yellow welcome to a new video this will
be a slight change from the hood from
the opening videos I'll do some war zone
video again playing them are we playing
the war zone final I should enter early
for forgetting that the war zone final
which is the longest tournament here on
chest Cupid's one hour so it will be a
long video and two minute games the
usual stuff with the doubling cube um
let's see what happens usually I get 8
ounce in the first game I always play
him almost and he is usually doing quite
a good job I think let's see what
happens trying to get some sharper
position I think he placed the solid
stuff pretty good ok we got the the
bangko or let's transpose to the
bloomfield gambit I don't know that
really but well maybe it's it's fun to
try out oh he's some just covering me
five okay I just ignore this and keep on
developing not sure what starts right
here I know his son but now i should i
should be able to take here let's give
this check first he needs to retreat and
now Bishop a6 prevents him from
canceling the shutter yeah okay what now
not see six
yeah let's develop first if he takes I
can take with the Queen and irritate him
further so what now maybe take this post
on the long diagonal or you could have
canceled okay play another center of
course the whole idea of this opening
maybe he can somehow distract me with
queen bee five four moves like this 95mm
yeah I need to be on oh this is strange
move hard to believe that white can
afford such stuff okay let's play a
foreign d4 yeah you can give a check
here and maybe take on c5 but I should
have so much positioner compensation I
don't mind okay d three rookie five
froakie 5-foot blunder here if I go
Knight g4 a tag f2 yeah I lost a lot of
time okay I need to speed up here
most likely this was in term we need
them the best continuation but now is in
a in a nasty pin not sure how you could
manage to unravel here just take it and
it's too low then unfold uncomfortable
pin check here
threatens made on h2 don't see a defense
really yeah mate yes was somewhat slow
went out okay is not a not a bad player
okay let's see I'm trying to mix
openings here against somewhat better
position i usually play d4 so for my my
usual stuff but against some wood weaker
opponents i also play when you form okay
this wasn't really what i intended looks
uncomfortable not not really well
developed here yeah maybe you can just
take si form yeah but the splendors
piece I did trust doubling up okay I did
okay let's get a 10 home trying to
complete development here you can take
on a 2 a.m. I don't mind much i need to
get my stuff out here i can just take
him yeah this is just an extra piece
he's got one poem
yeah my crank was this week try to get
to to the porn here this was somewhat
stupid I guess didn't bring much benefit
maybe I can get five now yeah it should
be six and i have the poor Nia ya b3 is
falling no only need to take take into
account to get get somewhat quicker
trying to get rid of the pin here and
now f5 is falling
oopsie 6 is made here nice this is
always nice that you don't have to get
into this uture turn problems ok I'm the
game's not starting I'm playing against
someone rated 2500 which is extremely
high just curious oh this is so yeah he
is rated that high sometimes you have
those people who just doing their first
tournament send the writing is so
distorted sometimes k let's somewhat
usually harmless line black should
shouldn't have any particular problems
but of course it's um it's a playable
line from white I think special for
black camel it's just an a good a good
position but no one clear advantage or
something
like to get rid of the night maybe you
will play night see fire photo I have
this square now try to get to be 6
yeah it's a pot equal I guess don't have
a good idea how to strengthen my
position okay I can I could try to
double all the evil maybe maybe this
night has some ideas on e 2 okay
I could take on III it's interesting
that's maybe not really enough time I
was slow oh yeah maybe i should i should
have psych this i like the idea but
didn't really bring much dividends
completely unnecessary and really
advanced the pretty ridiculous opening
okay okay yeah let's go to the next game
I could have just stay put there you
never get anything in this position okay
got a semi semi Slav just a pretty
standard position trying to open up the
center here okay well it was too to be
expected that you don't see the mate but
you can always try okay maybe I can play
this night g6 trick here how about yes
we should be six it's a stupid really
okay
around 95 wasn't a great move
it doesn't didn't make much sense really
you know he's got the bishop pair so I'm
not sure if getting into an end game was
so great or maybe I can play we should
be four to two yeah prevented that too
hard to to get rid of one of them
bishops the chalet for now maybe if i
get rid of game maybe i can go to d7
this is an idea you cannot play five
until it ties up his rooks a bit maybe
not so bad young okay i want to prevent
the doubling of the pawns at least for
now you know I've doubled on the default
maybe i can i can play before next yeah
let's go and b6 as a weakness so if i'm
not mistaken he's pretty much out plate
now i can take now I am I can take on g2
but it's no big deal yeah I've pretty
messy porn autoplay a five and then a
then one with the C porn
c6 the rookies just hanging ah great
stuff great stuff here and you I wanted
to play work look back first completely
ridiculous okay i play on a bit on time
not much else to do you should easily
get my ipod yeah can you do its
tournament and I lose so much games on
Tom ok next one but then obviously cried
out of shape here this was really really
unnecessary ok an Italian game
okay I'm trying to get something going
with f5 try to get some initiative here
on the king of course it's a pretty
solid four wide should be a in equal
position okay now i can take on h3 is
awesome trick well my g5 but no big deal
f3 is hanging now she takes Clint xf3
here just drop back here yeah okay this
threatens forget three
now I can get a steak yeah this is just
a pawn for nothing 12 to protect the
back rank with h6 first I'd like to
place his 695 if he lets me yeah it is
so I have gotten a weakness now on the
queenside well just be seven a bit but
he's got issues as well d 4 and back
rank assaults a week k check no here
alright let's just play play this
technical I'm game it's just an extra
porn and I've got the open file
and I'm somewhat ahead on the clock also
yeah but this should be pretty dangerous
now for white now make next move for
rookie one rookie one mate yep yeah
still somewhat behind losing the sir
this can work blundered the rook I hate
this the sky reform I played see file
then nothing ok let's try to get
something going quickly here with an
aggressive setup he's on minus 10 this
is quite quite amazing 2,000 something
usually should should have some points
yeah pretty typical position for this
opening what is always slightly better
with a space advantage but like it's
fairly solid
night a force a normal reaction white
wants to play c4 I'd really get lots of
space here on the queenside okay let's
hop into c5 only hope that this horner
doesn't get lost but I could also go G
for now trying to push this night back
usually black place h form and this
opening which here somehow didn't do
trying to protect c5 even more of course
I need to be cautious the neither some
exposed here but also could be
threatening something not sure if i
played this this writer Ellie Wendy 4f
Queenie for this should be a great
square so I don't mind if he wins the
pawn this way if it gives me white
should be okay rook h1 now it's my idea
yeah you can exchange the Queen set down
mind g5 okay he wants to drop back to g6
whatever play f5 is there some trick f5
no going for this huge space advantage
all right okay let's cover this yeah i'm
behind on the clock this is the only
issue position is sterile fo black ok
need to speed up here the night still
doesn't have a square just silly g6
yeah it's completely winning for white
but I have been slow yeah 1mon time with
an extra queen okay yeah i'm still in in
the hunt here but not really in good
shape yesterday I wonder thing with the
uture a utrom Arjun okay I've got some
boring Queens pawn opening is there some
way to get selective play em difficult I
guess trying to to get something here
yeah it's just terribly boring
of course black girl like has no
particular problems but hard to to get
some interesting play going and of
course you I was very close to two
cursing here he just offered to draw
just of course them one why should I
draw I mean okay it's terribly boring
but that doesn't stop black from trying
to win yeah I've got okay I've got ideas
for for Queen side play of course
minority time Authority attack style I
can get a night to see phone activate
rooks here okay wants to do 90 for more
slightly
he played this anyway I don't mind sir
the night exchange I've got the seafoam
yeah okay thank you sorry I just hate
those people you do nothing and just
play play some some crap stuff yet and
why should I take a draw yeah we'll just
lose some time but what's what's the
problem so my gears are up to now so
most likely you cannot it will lose on
time anyways a button yeah but this is
just ridiculous it does nothing in this
game up just using on time and offering
draws all the time okay I got a center
counter defense here Wow f5 talk about
the terrible move just weakening
everything ok on 95 with the idea of
Queen h5 should be pretty and powerful
already
yeah okay I could I could just take on
you six maybe even well let's just
retreat it's truth it's an extra ponent
you gtech for nothing basically okay
let's let's use all the pieces it's not
quite sure what the rook is doing but
yeah this gives the Nets the exchange at
least I will even more I cannot even
play Queenie eight so made on f7 it's
just just over yeah I'm still pretty far
behind so it will be difficult to to win
this tournament yeah some b3 opening of
course it's always difficult to have to
get something quickly going against
hasta those kind of openings it's pretty
solid okay now at least I've got an
isolated pawn maybe it's tempted to try
something all right
okay okay let's just centralized pieces
flow them maybe I can get something
going on the kingside would be the
normal plan here maybe we'll just drop
back to to deform okay 27 team i play
Knight c5 not sure if I want that ok
let's go back first him if he retreats I
am I'll go to g7
this way preventing 95 which would most
most likely cost me my bishop of course
I don't want to exchange it hmm yeah
he's just trying to exchange everything
off here 95 so ridiculous move most
likely this looks very strange on FYI I
wanted to secure when age three yeah
come on have some fun
oh it's not not without its merits here
if it takes I can maybe simply recapture
with the rook of course I can always
make a make this perpetual okay night
where g form let's go let you phone look
you can go rook f3 now
I don't want to draw I'm just not sure
what what to do ok opening it up must be
right
yeah this is not just winning now yeah i
think it was it was playable in a blitz
game okay we've got some open sicilian
here kind of scavenging an idle mixture
black hasn't canceled which is which is
really unusual and he didn't he didn't
make a room here first night so we had
to come to retreat her completely 2g8 I
guess some white should should have a
really great position now but I'm not
natural only four player now why should
be very good here actually good [ __ ] oh
wow okay preventing now Bishop Knight to
c4 for the time being maybe you wanted I
wanted to I wanted to make a square here
for the night okay I understand should
default to a tech g7 maybe or should I
try to prepare a five I try to prepare
five
b form
okay let's go back here yeah it's not
really created that I wanted to name
game but I wasn't sure what to do with
limited time I should reassess I should
have somehow played this differently he
just played complete rubbish in this
opening but I didn't refute it he had
this looks nice but I'm not sure if it's
so great for Black Sea for now as a
problem and I'm always i'm having some
ideas okay he cannot move the bishop now
and he doesn't have anything special
going here come on
yeah it's just winning now yeah okay
somehow came back there came in fourth
place of his place or something criminal
one or could really no one whatever
hmm take be to ram i will just take here
take here yeah you will get i would have
i I've got to check I've gotta check on
a one I can take this maybe it's
dangerous oh not sure well let's just
treat him
it was really dangerous to take this
porn I really shouldn't have done this
oh my yeah I couldn't resist somehow to
take this maybe it's still okay but I
want it it is ok but it's not very
comfortable
and I'm very much done on time yeah
useless I shouldn't have taken the pawn
just play some normal moves and outplay
this guy or less or try to outplay him
grabbing the porn just cost time course
you just just changes down into a lost
endgame tries to win a time
you have to at least I can secure the
draw here oops and I wouldn't have
managed to meeting anyway okay I'm
playing the tournament leader actually
assign crying no draw of course you play
some we are opening I'll just develop
star here
okay I've got some options here try to
threaten e5 or transfer the bishop here
we cannot publish 56 and now i can use
it five and now a form
yeah only problem is that it is a blitz
game widest I just winning I guess ok I
take them yeah yes sir ok I'll retreat
maybe I should have taken it was
possible technically I mean
prevent Bishop before using the pin now
here threatening Queen h5
on a silly game really completely silly
game
g2 and this time this is I didn't play
this even yeah one on time whatever
complete mess and I should have only
utterly refuted this rubbish opening
somehow I didn't manage to control the
position maybe I shouldn't have advanced
all those pawns so early it was it was
good but difficult to handle in blitz
okay we got the Ashley mahir he is
somehow 1 upon mostly because I was too
busy talking about about the the other
game all right how to get some
compensation
try to activate the PCM look to d8 and
just take first now trying to play c-51
I wants to play Quincy form better step
away uh-huh it should be 5 11
yeah yeah I've got two bishops this is
some slight compensation up on the pole
it's not quite enough but
how to do anything concrete here yeah I
got the better minor piece of course
bishop is stronger than an ID but still
on it should be enough compensation but
gave me the spawn for whatever reason h5
he might have this check better not not
an idea three check I mean okay no no
age five
now I can try to play Bishop g4 h5
grabbing a pawn I've got a huge space
its base advantage o is giving out the
porn just are voluntarily yeah this is
winning end game now
threatening King c3 now
yeah this one left me this phone no the
beep bonus running here come completely
misplayed this end game jam still I have
no chances for place free I didn't have
any really quick wins so stupid stuff
where the opponent just allows are made
or blunders a queen or something like
castling here of course ridiculous but
it just helps once in a while to to get
those easy points
yeah we got some French rare french line
yeah I grab this can't believe I shove
h3 right you know maybe the Rue can help
covering what just taking it with tempo
now I could even grab c7 why not
now if you take through p8 kingda 726
checkmate and well I'm threat going a
little something anyway yeah mid next
move I hope it doesn't let the clock run
down hmm maybe it does typical foolish
behavior no all right yeah maybe place
for ice falls within reach dissipating
canceling it happens so often yeah of
course black is Lady better now that's
what I'm talking about just a quick City
made to get points maybe if i get really
quick now win maybe I can try place too
but I need to cook when I just have 15
Gear games played the other guy here
please 22 okay it must be quick away
it's not a bad player okay let's try
some really okay no ultra aggressive
stuff possible
yeah I guess this is a bit silly what I
tried him but okay you can try but it's
Randy working now i just have yeah well
not much but still still of course it's
a playable position hmm all right good
move I don't want to get the rook to e3
now this is this is ok again maybe it's
even a little little something for me if
he continues to play such stuff maybe
what's a little something I have chances
to get the night to see form
and then I have a really nice position
yeah what a d5 Eden this is actually
threatening to win apiece okay be six or
a seven very nice position now maybe I
should have prevented if all ok I'm not
sure yeah I can try this I still got the
default down i prevented this at least
ok maybe I can exchange whoops with rook
e8 very direct approach a bishop t8o
should be aids silly put in putting the
night there I need to get it back as
soon as possible
how to win this of course why it is just
better but maybe it's not possible to
win I to a form is king b6 maybe get the
night to d3 try to simultaneously attack
both pawns didn't help much okay now i
have c form from the 90 i can prep them
yeah it was winning in the end to
expunge but of course this was hard to
slow to get any chance to to fight for
third place
yeah some sort of Vienna Kings gambit
whatever mixture with nothing much
happening sure maybe you can take on c7
but I 46 makes an active impression at
least
trying to address Queen and Bishop here
Queenie three maybe he needs to play
rook e8 t4 and f6 and I winning this
Bishop could be yeah okay I need to be
cautious up on f8 so I should secure
some square still I can take I think he
just just got one check and that's it
counter taking on g2
ok
hmm didn't take that into account really
okay let's exchange queens now at least
I shouldn't get mated
yeah the tourney is completed it tells
me yeah okay yeah six plays which is not
brilliant but somehow I had very few
quick wins I only played 16 games yeah
this is this is just just not enough
yesterday I had 30 30 games strange how
how big those differences are sometimes
yeah well I still hope it was
entertaining to watch I even know want
some rating points I didn't play that
bad I think um compared to some people
here I had also much stronger position
but maybe she was that I am didn't have
many quick wins you need some some quick
wins too yeah just get in points quickly
and somehow i didn't i didn't have those
yeah well thanks for watching hope it
was entertaining and yeah talk to you
soon with new videos